In this section, we will explore how version control is handled in the engine, starting
with the latest version of Unreal Engine.
Unreal Engine allows users to directly connect to their fully integrated version control
solution by navigating to the Tools pull-down menu in the main menu and then navigating
through to the Revision Control section.
Here you will be able to select the Connect to Revision Control option, and that will
bring up a pop-up menu allowing you to select your Revision Control provider.
In addition to Perforce, Unreal Engine supports Subversion, Git, and PlasticCSM.
Once the provider is selected, users can input their Revision Control server, username,
and workspace.
If established in the Unreal Engine Settings, users can automatically connect by enabling
the established P4 config.
Once you've made a successful connection, Unreal Engine will notify you with a pop-up
in the lower right-hand corner.
Additionally, the Quick Access menu for Revision Control is located in the lower
right-hand corner of any active window in Unreal Engine.
This Quick Access Revision Control menu will also allow users to make any changes
to the Revision Control settings, modify files, or utilize any of the version control
options from the Action menu.
The Revision Control menu options will change depending on the state of your checked
asset, and additional options will become active or inactive depending on your Version
Control provider.
The most commonly used menu actions are going to be Checkout, Mark for Add, Check
In, and Revert.
When making changes to assets, maps, or pretty much anything within your Unreal Engine project,
you will need to start by checking out the files that you want to modify.
To do that, you simply need to right-click on the asset, go to the Revision Control
options, and check out those files directly.
Once you've checked out a file, you will note that the file itself will have
an icon appear in the lower right-hand corner.
This red Check Mark icon shows that the file has been checked out for modification.
Additionally, as you go through your Version Control, you're going to find a few different
icons that identify the state of any new or checked out file that needs to be submitted
with Version Control active.
So any time a file is changed, it must be checked out of Version Control either
directly or as part of a mass checkout through the Quick Access Revision Control
menus in the lower right-hand corner.
This will allow any modified files to be checked out prior to saving.
So if you're working on a level, and you notice that little asterisk, then that
file needs to be saved.
But so too would any sublevels need to be saved, and while you might not see the asterisks
for those sublevels, the Check Out Modified Files option won't miss them.
When you are ready to run through the Check Out Modified Files option, it will automatically
open a pop-up menu that will allow you to select those files for modification and
add the red Check Mark indicator to those files just like we talked about in the last
slide.
Once you are finished making all of your modifications, you are ready to submit your
changes to the Version Control system.
When files need to be checked back in to your Version Control provider, simply go back
to that Quick Access Revision Control menu in the lower right-hand corner to submit
your saved content.
This will bring up a Submit Files pop-up menu.
From there, check the assets you wish to submit or verify that they are already checked
and then fill out the change list much like you did when working inside Perforce directly.
Additionally, you have the option to keep files checked out if you want to continue
working on them after you've made the submission.
Once you click the Submit button, the submission will process and you will receive
another pop-up notifier in the bottom right-hand corner of the engine that says the submission
is successful and it will provide you a new change list number.
Verify that change list number from the pop-up notification with the Version Control history
inside your Version Control provider after the submission is complete.
Alright, that's it for this section.
In our next section, we will look at how Unreal Engine for Fortnite handles Version
Control.